Kovach I Sayed Copic I never dies bet
your ass Cobra Kai so Cobra Kai is a
YouTube read series is about ten half an
hour long episodes on YouTube YouTube
read as a service you have to pay for
but you get a four one month free trial
so Cobra Kai is the story of Johnny from
Karate Kid it's been decades since the
original Karate Kid it does take place
in 2018 Karate Kid was mid 80s it's been
many decades since that first tournament
Daniel Larusso owns a successful car
dealership
Johnny's luck hasn't been so good so
Johnny opens a karate dojo in the valley
under the name Cobra Kai so now Johnny's
kind of the Miyagi only not anything
like Miyagi what I love about this is
this show does show us the other side of
it one thing Karate Kid never did was
ask Johnny side of things there was that
joke on around the internet I think it
was in the form of a YouTube video and a
Facebook post and a hundred other things
well if you look at it Daniel was kind
of the bully and Karate Kid and though
that is an extreme it does show that
there are two sides to that or two sides
to that tale what's Johnny's side of it
you kind of get Johnny's side of it
because the students that sign up to be
Cobra Kai it's not like they're the
[ __ ] you knew Cobra Kai in the
original Karate Kid really these kids
are scared they have bully problems in
high school so it makes you go maybe
that was the story of the Cobra Kai in
the original Karate Kid maybe they
didn't start out as [ __ ] maybe they
just started out as kids who were scared
to go to school really what this show
does well is the semantics of good guy
bad guy doesn't really exist here in
this story sometimes Johnny's the hero
sometimes he's a bit extreme and he runs
into Ralph Macchio Daniel Larusso and
sometimes Daniels alright sometimes he's
a bit of a dick too it sheds the layers
of Daniels the good guy John he's the
bad guy maybe they both have their good
moments maybe they both have their
douchebag moments which makes them
complex human beings among the
perspectives there's Daniel and Johnny
Johnny and Daniel Johnny and his
students a couple of his students in
their dating situation in high school
didn't you have Johnny's actual son his
relationship with Johnny and you have
Daniel and him I mean just it's there's
a lot of layers of this thing but I also
like is the fact that Johnny's just he's
not squeaky clean
this dude is nothing like Miyagi it kind
of reminds me of the Spider Man mantra
is with great power comes great
responsibility and they came out with a
Scarlet Spider comic book where Scarlet
Spider was super hardcore and it's
a clan was all the power none of the
responsibility Johnny kinda reminds me
of that he'll tell the students like
alright you need to get punched to the
face because you can't be [ __ ] and
then then being young kids in 2018
they're like oh that reinforces gender
stereotypes and he doesn't give a [ __ ]
and I really like that because there's
no way you could have this damaged
person who was in his heyday in the 80s
and now he's just kind of a burnout
there's nobody can have that character
and have him be so PC in this day and
age I do in shows and movies do that
they want to show you someone who's
really gruff and rough around the edges
but you still got to keep it clean for
Twitter not this show not with Johnny
actually like that call what I love most
about the show is it is the tailors
oldest I'm someone who starts something
that he himself was a part of when he
was young but he's like I'm not gonna do
it the way it was I'm gonna do it better
this time but when you use the same
tactics you don't make it better it just
keeps the wheel going it reinforces a
cycle and the end fight of this season
was actually it was quite profound by
the end I was like these are levels of
depth I didn't expect in Cobra Kai cuz
in the end Cobra Kai was surprisingly
good and surprisingly deep it's a look
at the Karate Kid trope through
different angles different perspectives
that's what it is it's a celebration of
perspectives what's Johnny's side of it
what's Daniels side of it what are the
Cobra Kai students side of it did they
see themselves as bad do they see
themselves as [ __ ] or maybe the road
to hell is paved with good intentions
this was a remarkably good time in one
sitting I just binge daal ten episodes
on YouTube read I got myself a 30-day
free trial I believe that's just
standard so you watch Cobra Kai then
cancel it alright so Cobra Kai have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more Cobra
Kai never die
[Music]